welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he is away on vacation
yesterday's Rose Garden Fiasco is the
gift that keeps giving a close-up shot
of Donald Trump's notes that he
scribbled in order to give that
fascinating speech that he gave
yesterday revealed that the President of
the United States cannot spell
accomplishment now that's a joke that
works on many levels I mean there's
layers to that thing I mean he can't
even spell accomplishment and he's not
really racking up the accomplishments
but I'll leave that to a real comedian
but take a look at this picture he
actually wrote these things down
he said we believe that the president of
the u.s. is engaged in a cover-up which
is a direct quote from speaker Pelosi he
put quote most transparent he wanted to
remind us that he was the most
transparent that they want to impeach me
over acts that they did I know you are
but what am i and then here's the one
Dems have no accomplishments alcohol
looks like it was smelling alcohol
alcoholism and then I'm going to keep
working for the American people listen
I'm very loathe to to mock ignorance you
know no I'm guy Who am I fooling
especially when it comes to to Donald
Trump like conservatives this is your
guy this is your Savior I mean here's
another thing about this story right all
of that rambling he did yesterday where
he was extremely incoherent extremely
uncouth made absolutely no sense and
should concern every American person
while most of us thought it was
completely impromptu this dude literally
wrote notes and actually thought about
the stuff that he said yesterday I could
excuse it if it was an alcohol driven
just rant but instead this is the Rizzo
of Donald Trump actually thinking never
mind the fact that he can't spell
accomplishments never mind he spells
accomplishments almost as though he's
trying to spell alcoholism never mind
all that
the president's performance yesterday in
the Rose Garden is the result of him
actually thinking stuff through what
happens when this man actually just goes
off the cuff what happens when he just
actually I mean wow there's really
nothing else to say about this other
than holy crap look what can look what
democracy can give us and I love
democracy but seriously we've got a
president who actually thinks his
stupidity all the way through to the
misspelling of alcohol commissioners